ich habe mich und den anderen mitunter
gekickt
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer runde brief ich muss ein bisschen
leiser reden weil es gerade schon
relativ spät abends oasis viertel noch
zehn aber meine eltern meine schwester
venture blabla
jedenfalls möchte ich euch erst mal ganz
kurz blieb erkennt lief sollte
eigentlich jeder kennen hier ich spiele
es auf der haid pixel highspeed pixel
server postbrief ist ein fachmann ist
auf einer fläche voll mit tee und man
kriegt nachher nach einem countdown
bogen und bogen und pfeile bekommt man
und mann hat unendlich viel bzw einen
bogen mit verzauberungen unendlichkeit 1
und man das board hat jemand ab sieht
man gerade also ich kann es mir die
magic klopp machen hier viele spieler
naja egal jedenfalls gibt es halt die
möglichkeit dass man danach diesen bogen
bekommt bzw jeder diese möglichkeit
bekommt diesen bogen und man muss dann
diese pfeile schießen auf dem tier
müssen wo die anderen spieler runter
laufen dann fällt der us cent herunter
und dann fallen die anderen spieler auch
runter und bla bla bla bla bla
also ich bin jetzt einfach mal hier
eingetreten ist es gerade 21 auf dem vip
dingsbums sogar ganz gut weil erkennen
allen fast gar keiner und die leute sind
gut drauf das sind die die wirklich das
gerne spielen allerdings sind dann auch
wieder die prozess wegen ich habe noch
gar keine runde gewonnen und müsste dann
noch jeden moment losgehen dann werden
wir in dieser arena hier unten in die
hier werden wir ein geortet und dann
habe ich zb bogen müssen dann rumlaufen
müssen dann die tnt es abschließend wo
die andere leute sind hier seht ihr das
gerade dass jeder 12 sekunden ich gehe
ich erst mal ganz kurz an rand
am besten kommen hier passt schon so und
dann werden wir von jetzt mal ein paar
leute abschieds beziehen wir hoffen dass
keiner uns abschießen und das ist eine
relativ angenehm runde wird oder geht
direkt auf mich scheiße
das war schon richtig richtig neustadt
war dass alle schießt am anfang eine
mitte deswegen ist das relativ doof dann
wenn wir den anfang überlebt ist
eigentlich alles gut
nein ist das war knapp nein das war auch
relativ knapp auch mann
ich habe doch mal diese blöden lag die
ganze zeit dass ich hier nicht weg
er wollte mich umbringen
jeder viel ein umbringen das ist einfach
das spiegelt so ich versuche jetzt
erstmal jetzt nicht in die röhre
besondere pussy das ist einfach das
spiel das man wegläuft und ab und zu
hören immer mal ein bisschen schießt
nein
ob man das ist immer so unglaublich
knapp es ist traurig traurig traurig
du gehst weg fakt dass alles klappt das
ist gerade aber nur noch acht spieler
übrig das schon mal eine gute bilanz ich
weiß nicht habe ich dem töten weil ich
das keine ahnung ich weiß es nicht
das war ich nicht so hier geht keiner
auf mich das schon mal ganz gut dann
kann ich jetzt erstmal ein bisschen
schön und in der versuch mutter zu
kicken
ich glaub ich muss ein bisschen weiter
schießen so der da hinten wenn ich den
krieg nicht gut dann krieg ich auch
nicht
und der ist noch nicht tot der
erkenntnis tot weil er ganz hinten
versuche ich jetzt auch mal okay ich bin
unter den top drei alte das war ich noch
nie das ist so dieses aufnahme dingsda
bin ich dann immer auf einmal viel
besser nein eigentlich ist es immer das
gegenteil
okay da hinten die lasse ich jetzt
erstmal jetzt ein bisschen wir kriegen
so schnell weiter hier so schnell rüber
als wenn ich erster werden schreibt das
auch ein titel das ist mir egal ob ich
das bin oder nicht
ich glaube da denkt der weiß dass ich
einen tag mehr kennt mich glaube ich
vielleicht irgendwo her
der weiße dem bringt zuerst und dann
habe ich zudem profi für nachher so nach
dem motto ich höre dass das team weiter
auf den fersen simyo de ist auch einfach
nur auf mich nein denn wer fast
runtergefallen ob man das war
unglaublich knapp wieder
ich muss einfach mal von den beiden
jetzt wieso können die beiden sich ja
nicht einfach mal bekriegen so schnell
weglaufen als eigentlich daran die
runden gehen die runde man relativ
schnell vorbei jetzt gerade dort auf
jeden fall schon vor lange kann ich mir
einfach einer von beiden runterfallen
die gehen beide nur auf mich scheiße
dass ich mich fast selber unter gekriegt
jetzt gerade vor also jump'n'run muss
ich sagen wie ich mir eins geben
ich habe mich und den anderen mitunter
gekickt auch mal nicht denn so dumm
freunde wegen noch eine runde dran wo
alter also ich kann gerade nicht mit
emotionen dabei sein das tut mir auch
leid aber boah krass
na gut da habe ich mich einfach mal
selber runter ich dachte na gut
schade man einfach noch nicht mal das
geht dann relativ schnell wenn man hier
youtube stil youtube ich freue mich
richtig drüber weil ich auch relativ auf
dem server wenn ich aufnehmen so der da
bewegt sich gar nicht möchte am liebsten
ein weg der sich am anfang gar nicht
bewegt alter ich kann ihnen gar nicht
darunter schießen sich gerade
habe ich überhaupt schon gerade eine
untergeschossen hier soll insgesamt also
jetzt erst mal wieder ein bisschen
verteidigen hoffen dass die anderen sich
irgendwie gegenwärtig abschießen
auch nur noch neun spieler alter das
ging schnell sieht mich überhaupt einmal
auf mich gehen der geht da geht auf mich
nur auf mich gehts dann gehe ich auf
dich okay okay ich hoffe nur auf mich
was will der sucht die andere leute auch
nur noch fünf leute übrig
welcher munter kicken will dann denen
der geht nur auf mich eigentlich dass
ein amerikanischer server wo mich
eigentlich fast kein erkennen sollte
löffelstiel dannecker nicht viel kennen
sich nicht einfach mal vergessen
es gibt so viele leute hier geht nur auf
mich ich hasse solche leute chance ihn
ich hasse ihn so sehr liebe hierüber
hier wenn ich mich jetzt um 3 unter die
bis hinter mir
es ist echt schon krass erbärmlich ich
konnte auf einmal nicht mehr sprinten
ich habe keine ahnung warum ich hab' ich
konnte auf einmal überspringen
nat
dass man verpiss dich jetzt
wenn nämlich jetzt können wir dachten
ich kenn dich
der gewinn von den beiden da hinten ist
der venturi o2 den ihn okay
er kennt mich cfds
ich weiß dass im englischen nicht gibt
bzw ist da anders
levent uhr los und schon jetzt besiegt
für sich verpissen alter ich hab kein
bock auf typen
fucking deal soll nämlich ganze zeit
verfolgten ist er selber schuld
tschüss schreibt nicht hügel fällt mit
belboon das ist einfach ich habe tausend
mal gesagt wenn ihr mich auf server
verfolgt oder mich andersweitig
irgendwie nervt dann mache ich das nicht
mehr
und dann habe ich auch keine lust daran
das habe ich tausend mal gesagt und es
hat mir auch 1000 leute gesagt hätte
luca was habt ihr gegen 13 jährige ich
habe gesagt dass ich die meisten
zuschauer bei mir 50 prozent sind zwölf
bzw
13 jährige und in dem alter ist man euch
ausgereift aufwendig 12 und 13 jährige
meistens sehr reif fühlen sind sie nicht
reif ich habe mich mit 13 jahren auch
reife die welt gefühlt reif dafür
gefühlt zu arbeiten und alles mögliche
zu machen
allerdings wenn man dann noch ein paar
jahre älter ist sieht man die
13-jährigen mit komplett anderen augen
so das ist ein pädagogisches phänomen
bzw
das ist einfach kann man pädagogisch zu
beweisen es ist genauso wie wenn ihr
fünf zelte oder so denkt ihr mit 55 mit
anderen fünfjährigen fühlt euch super
korrekt und denkt ihr seid die
allergrößten und die allerbesten in der
gesellschaft und die kommt mit allen
klar und blau allerdings wenn ihr dann
zwei jahre älter seid denkt dieser alten
mädchen die schweizer mit 5
das geht bis in das erwachsenenalter so
also das war eine sehr schlechte runde
naja ich hab nichts gegen zwei
13-jährige wenn sie sich vernünftig
benehmen wenn sie sich nicht vernünftig
benehmen habe ich gegen alle personen
was in egal welches alter sage ich dann
auch einfach meine meinung und wenn mich
leute auf der straße an quatschen
hinterherlaufen nicht schocken und alles
möglich machen dann hab ich kein bock
damit sich auf servern verfolgen so dass
möchte muss sich erstmal ganz gut sagen
will jobmäßig ja sonst will ich euch
sagen wenn ihr mehr als postbrief wollt
dann gibt einfach den daumen hoch
das würde mich sehr freuen und dann
sehen wir uns beim nächsten mal wieder
typisch